the 17th wnba all-star game taking place
here in las vegas right now
kevin martin joining us now live from
the mklobe ultra arena previously known
as the mandalay bay events center
with more tonight hi kevin
well hey guys yeah it's halftime here at
the wma all-star game with team wnba
leading the usa team by 1.44
to 43 and we spoke about this pregame
that
the players were all saying you know
typically during an
all-star game the players get to relax
and have some
fun and you know show off a bit but this
year
it's been a little bit more competitive
because team usa
is using this as an exhibition game to
of course get ready
for the tokyo olympics so we have seen a
great game so far
four league changes tied six times
las vegas aces asia wilson has four
points and two rebounds in the first
half chelsea gray has two points dereka
hamby has two points liz cambage
has not seen any of the action but like
i said
the fans that are inside for this one
and the fans
that are tuning in at home are enjoying
a really tight one here
it's very competitive a lot of fun and
there's really a lot of stars in the
house
andre drummond nba star demar derozan
of course as i mentioned earlier mark
davis they're all in the house
so a lot of fun and we are treated to a
very competitive game of course
we'll keep you updated on the wnba
all-star coming up at six
reporting live at the mickel lobe ultra
arena kevin martin 8 sports now
kevin